c'est la grande bataille du quinquennat
la réforme des retraites que le
gouvernement souhaite faire adopter dès
cette année c'est une partie de
l'opposition est des syndicats
considèrent ce projet de loi comme
contraire aux intérêts des travailleurs
restent que tout le monde n'est pas
concerné par le nouvel âge de départ la
première ministre Elisabeth borne l'a
dit elle-même 4 français sur 10 pourront
partir à la retraite avant 64 ans qui
sont-ils et surtout en fait vous partis
[Applaudissements]
en effet certaines catégories de
travailleurs ne sont pas concernés par
le report que le gouvernement souhaite
introduire il y a tout d'abord les
personnes reconnues comme inapte au
travail en France elles étaient plus de
100 000 en 2019 selon l'inspection
générale des affaires sociales avec près
de 700 000 nouveaux retraités chaque
année selon le ministère du Travail cela
représente donc un septième des départs
il pourrait bénéficier d'une retraite à
taux plein en s'arrêtant de travailler à
62 ans sans minimum de trimestre dans la
réforme cette retraite pour inaptitude
née en 1945 le gouvernement n'y
toucherait pas l'exécutif prévoit
également de simplifier le dispositif de
retraite pour incapacité permanente afin
que toute personne ayant eu un accident
de travail ou une maladie
professionnelle ayant entraîné une
incapacité d'au moins 10% puisse partir
deux ans avant l'âge légal si cette
incapacité est liée à une exposition à
des facteurs de pénibilité enfin les
travailleurs en situation de handicap
pourront partir à la retraite des 55 ans
à condition d'avoir cotisé 112
trimestres soit 28 ans
été associé mais on avait aussi un petit
inquiétude sur le sujet du reportage sur
les conditions d'en des bénévoles qui
sont des jeunes retraités concernant les
travailleurs en situation de handicap
donc nous on constate quand même il faut
quand même le dire que les deux régimes
qui sont leur sont dédiés que ce soit la
retraite anticipée des travailleurs
handicapés et la retraite pour
inaptitude sont maintenues et préservés
donc ça quand même c'est un acquis
important puisque pour nous faut quand
même mentionner que
les personnes en situation de handicap
dans l'emploi connaissent des fragilités
particulières ce qu'on souhaite c'est
que le régime en particulier de la
retraite anticipée des travailleurs
handicapés soient davantage améliorés
dans les faits ils ont beaucoup de mal
la plupart des personnes à être
éligibles parce que il y a des
conditions qui sont très drastiques à la
fois sur le nombre d'années cotisés en
tant que travailleur handicapé qui est
quand même très conséquente autre
catégorie les travailleurs exposés à
l'amiante il bénéficierait eux aussi
d'un des parts anticipés à la retraite
nous allons conserver et améliorer le
dispositif du carrière longue en le
rendant plus juste et plus lisible
en 2030 lorsque l'âge légal de départ à
la retraite aura été portée à 64 ans il
restera à 58 ans pour ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler très tôt avant 16
ans de nouveaux seuils ont cependant été
établis pour les personnes ayant
commencé avant leur 18 ans le départ ne
pourra se faire qu'à partir de leur 60
ans pour ça l'ayant commencé entre 18
ans et 20 ans l'âge sera fixé à 62 ans
il y a par ailleurs une profession qui
s'est mobilisée en 2020 et qui a
jusque-là réussi à garder ses acquis ce
sont les avocats dont le régime autonome
ne devrait pas changer il bénéficie
également d'un régime complémentaire
réformé en 2015 ces deux régimes de
retraite sont gérés conjointement par la
Caisse nationale des barreaux français
les marins également ne sont pas
concernés leur régime permettrait aux
salariés du secteur de partir dès l'âge
de 50 ans après 25 années de service
autre annonce du gouvernement le
maintien du dispositif des catégories
actives qui permet à certains
fonctionnaires de bénéficier d'un départ
anticipés à la retraite entre 52 et 57
ans cela concerne les fonctionnaires
occupant un emploi présentant un risque
particulier ou occasionnant des fatilles
exceptionnelles dans ce cas précis
attention ces fonctionnaires seraient
bien concernés par l'âge de départ fixé
à 64 ans mais il pourrait demander à
partir plutôt à la retraite s'ils ont pu
passer assez de temps en service actif
et enfin les personnes nées avant août
1961 ne devraient pas être concernés par
le report de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite elles pourront partir dès l'âge
de 62 ans dès cette année